[Music]
I found Santa Claus [__] around on my
roof so I imprisoned him with my Cube no
Christmas this year sorry my
Cube what is this for
dude so it's people who like that that's
an air is that an air thing okay and
then the other hoses are sucking the air
out of the box
what would that feel like scary bro I
was going to say hot as
hell porno filmed in the Senate yeah we
saw that yeah I saw like that's old news
I now mat I like that gesture when you
did that that's old news old news now
Matthew MCC you watch that guy get
clapped I actually I didn't see the
video but I saw saw three seconds of the
dude getting clapped it was kind of
crazy I saw the thumbnail then I was
like I don't want to watch this dude was
just
panning why he's just bouncing who is
panning there's a third person the uh
the um oh it's the guy doing the the
batter yeah yeah I don't know what you
call it yeah the The Giver the batter
and the to and the catcher yeah yeah the
guy pitcher that's what it is no the guy
batting is the one
filming yeah it was crazy just panting
while just tearing this dude's ass up
Noel looks extra [__] today have you
two ever explored each other's bodies
what I love just like the out of context
just what has Tik Tok done to you
guys what has Tik Tok done to you guys
bro has literally never explored
explored bro's body that's what's next
wait did you see that tweet that was
like I'm with my Zoomer cousin at the
aquarium no zomer little brother spent
the entire aquarium trip today pointing
and either going that fish is locked in
or that fish is tweaking no in
between with a tight ass hoodie
strawberry carts yeah yeah yo he
tweaking that fish is locked in yo that
fish is tweaking I've been getting a lot
of um that fish is locked in I've been
getting a lot of lean heads on my
Twitter timeline drinking lean yeah is
it back in I think it's I think so for
some people never went away I think I
think that we went through a period of
like Xanax and lean they were like very
mainstream yeah now it's I feel like
Lean Like A bunch of rappers even were
like vocal about vocal about quitting
lean saw Lil Nar put uh
he posted a clip of his house he he has
um like a water dispenser but it's
lean it's it's Grim dude that's sad yeah
it's sad that is [__] sad
yeah put this in the organ Trail man how
expensive do you think that would be
[__] I don't know 100 Grand
yeah I'm dying thinking about putting
this in the middle of like settler
America in the middle of like a gold
Russ town that there's the magic purple
stuff they got these Cowboys leaned out
and
[__] that is [__] crazy so insane man
add one to the ship yeah yeah yeah we're
talking about next Christmas how do we
wind up
ourselves Cody spank me please we didn't
talk about poop at all no we still two
minutes left we could just watch two
minutes of someone Just sh in we just
watch two girls one cup actually yeah
let's turn it on man let's finish this
out wait can you play the two girls one
cup piano that piano is haunting man
yeah yeah play that on YouTube just two
girls [__] immediate immediate how did
you have that so quick how did you have
that so
quick I can see the poop in my mouth
that's a button on the stream deck
dude it should be actually we should
have this it's [__] anime
ass
cry oh my God I'm
de run it back this this would be an
anime ready it's
like you have
to
okay there's no time left
it's to save us all but I don't know if
I'll see you again it doesn't
matter eat the [__]
[__]
okay and she
just and the Earth is
healing yeah and then it's just eating
poop I got to watch some anime if that's
what it is you do man hold on let's get
this guy to close it out no scroll up
the second one this guy just playing it
this is hysterical man
dude it's so sobody in the middle of it
some just shits all over the piano I'm
so pissed alen and I should have walked
out to this on our
wedding like like four random dudes in
the crowd that are kind of
like more guys in the crowd are like
they're
[Music]
[Laughter]
like what's wrong honey stomach
[Music]
issues it's so funny be so funny if you
recognized out this out in public cuz
you couldn't like ask anyone playing
playing be like playing this at an
airport yeah yeah dude down at the
[__] piano airport piano at the Delta
terminal and play this [__] see if
someone comes up yo yo is that the you
mind if
not please by all means
yeah flight 76 looking for passenger
Johnny
Gutierrez please come to gate 26a we are
this is the last call for
boarding yo what why do I recognize this
song that you're
playing this song what is this song I
recognize it it's weird I like memories
of this song but I can't put my finger
on what it is then you just look over in
the corner as a girl eating [__] yeah
yeah yeah he's got his little phone
out all
[Laughter]
right I can't remember this song but I
have a boner right now I'm weirdly horny
I'm weirdly turned on [__] man wow what
a solid ending dude with the Timbits and
the Tim Hortons thank you guys so much
much should we play it one more time and
get us out of here yeah yeah let's let's
play it out get let's get the original
though let's get the
original yeah we can do a nice outro I
guess this is like the last time we're
recording yeah thank you everyone for
tuning in to this live bonus it was
[Laughter]
awesome [__] hurt so
bad
that hit my
KNE Matthew come on in for using my new
[__]
treadmill I'm not joking that hit me
right here thank you everyone for tuning
in um thank you for another year of
watching the show we will uh we'll see
you next year got some best of episodes
coming out as always man we appreciate
you and we hope to see you very soon
thank you guys so much man I'm in so
much pain no thank you appreciate it and
uh I guess I [__] it up I could have
just let you end it as the song was
ending that's fine Crank that music yeah
soldier
boy thank you for an amazing
year we'll see you next
[Music]
year